et soudani bonjour merci d'être avec
nous aujourd'hui sur rt france on l'a
dit un quinze jours de couvre feu mis en
place depuis juillet à tunis c'est une
mesure nécessaire selon vous face à
l'augmentation du nombre de cas dans la
capitale oui alors c'est une mesure qui
a été globalement assez bien accueilli
par la population du grand tunis
il faut savoir qu il régnait un climat
anxiogène ces dernières 72 heures où
l'on est montée quand même un plus de
1200 cas par jour en moyenne de tests
positifs cela peut paraître peu cela
peut paraître pour des pays comme la
france qui ressource et 18 cas jusqu'à
récemment mais il faut comprendre que la
tunisie avait vécu une success story en
réalité au sortir du premier confinement
les morts se comptaient que par dizaines
et les cas positifs par centaines
donc le gouvernement harper qui a une
part démissionné cet été pouvait se
prévaloir de ce succès or depuis ce
qu'on a ce qu'on a observé c'est une
forme de relâchement
peut-être qu on a péché par excès de
confiance finalement il ya un flottement
par rapport à la codification couleurs
des pays desquels on recevait des
visites
la france et l'italie notamment son
passé du vert puis au goût rouge bio
orange est maintenant encore au rouge et
donc la population en fait
ras-le-bol de ce qui se passe sur le
plan politique où nous avons affaire à
un gouvernement qui n'a pas encore qu'il
est pas encore en poste depuis à peine
un mois et qui est qui vit une
cohabitation la réalité politiquement il
est important de souligner que le chef
du gouvernement via une présentation
avec le président de la république et
c'est de marquer des points politiques
et donc cela dit la population se plaint
du manque de transparence du coût d'une
communication défaillante de sa classe
politique
donc c'est ce couvre-feu qui allait être
encore plus strictes au départ décidé
proposé sur décidé sur proposition du
gouverneur de tunis vient clarifier les
choses et vient mettre tout le monde
d'accord
même si la tunisie à une économie
exemple aujourd'hui cela rassure la
population globalement ces satanés vous
nous dites que les relations entre le
premier ministre actuel et son président
peuvent parfois compliqué les mesures
prises par tout le monde justement dans
l'intérêt des tunisiens en partie
justement à cause de ceux de scoville 19
absolument au moment où le pays
on pourrait croire que c'est maintenant
ou jamais où on a besoin d'une union
nationale d'un élan d'union nationale
entre membres de la classe dirigeante
des élites du pays
or les tunisiens voudrait voir leur
ministre de la santé
convoqué une conférence de presse au
sein d'une communication de crise
manière quotidienne à heure fixe
mais ce n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui il
ya un flottement d'ailleurs jusqu'à hier
les tunisiennes ne savait pas à quelle
heure exactement allait être décrété le
couvre feu
et ça cela complique effectivement là
les rapports entre les institutions de
l'exécutif alors qu'aujourd'hui nous
avons à un exécutif où le numéro un le
l'homme le plus puissant du pays riches
mais chichis elle était encore en poste
je vous dis depuis un mois et essayent
tant bien que mal donc de connaître ses
dossiers
vu que la transition n'a pas été
évidente et encore la semaine dernière
le ministre de la culture a été limogé
d'une façon spectaculaire parce qu'il
était considéré comme l'un des hommes du
président de la république suite à son
refus publics d'appliquer les mesures
sanitaires dans les salles de cinéma
dans les théâtres et donc il a été
remercié sur le champ et donc c'est dire
à quel point nous vivons aujourd'hui une
situation où finalement le couvre-feu
est aussi à une constitue une solution
de la facilité en réalité pour imposer
l'ordre
c'est sous d'année vous vous en parliez
tout à l'heure un les chiffres peuvent
paraître peu un comparé à ce que l'on
connaît en france ou encore en espagne
je les rappelle en tunisie 24 mille cas
recensés depuis le début de l'épidémie
300 morts selon les chiffres officiels
mille cas positif actuellement par jour
est ce que le gouvernement tunisien
aujourd'hui a peur et est inquiet et
justement essaye de mettre un peu d des
mesures en place tant bien que mal
oui c'est à dire que le dilemme encore
une fois pour le gouvernement les
autorités publiques en tunisie c'est la
situation économique du pays
il ya une semaine encore on parlait
juste de retirer les des chaises dans
les dents les terrasses des cafés alors
ya eu une levée de boucliers de la part
de la principale chambre patronale du
pays est aujourd'hui encore début
octobre à la bad qui est là la banque
européenne pour la reconstruction et le
développement parle estime que la
tunisie sur l'année 2020 aura une
croissance de moins 8
et ça cela il faut se représenter les
scénarios les plus alarmistes parle de
-21 % sur le troisième trimestre donc ça
ça correspond pour une population de 12
millions d'habitants à la destruction
pure et simple de 160 mille emplois donc
c'est donc c'est dramatique pour les ce
nouveau gouvernement qui essayent dont
le chef du gouvernement pense à 2024 aux
élections présidentielles mais est qui
et qui voudrait que éviter qu'un jour on
lui dise mais vous n'avez pas pris les
mesures nécessaires
quand vous étiez au pouvoir donc c'est
toujours une fine le gros lot marche sur
des oeufs pour d'un côté essayer de
limiter les dégâts d'une société d'une
saison touristique existante on a on
parle de simplement 70 mille touristes
cette année en tunisie pour qui le
tourisme représente 7 à 8% du pib et
donc les autorités font ce qu'elles
peuvent en attendant de pouvoir a
peut-être demander aux européens de
d'effacer sa dette notamment
merci beaucoup c'est soudani d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
politique au courrier de l'atlas merci
beaucoup